so when I was a kid this was my team i
stunk at sports I don't like to play
them and then like to watch them this is
what I did I went fishing and for all of
my growing up I fished on the shores of
Connecticut and these are the creatures
that I saw on a regular basis but after
I grew up and went to college and I came
home in the early 90s this is what I
found my team had shrunk it was like
literally having your roster devastated
and as I sort of looked into that from a
very personal point of view as a
fisherman I started to kind of figure
out well what was the rest of the world
thinking about it first place I started
to look with fish markets and when I
went to fish markets in spite of where I
was whether it's in North Carolina or
Paris or London or wherever I kept
seeing this weirdly repeating trope of
for creatures again and again on the
menus on ice shrimp tuna salmon and Cod
and I thought this was pretty strange
and as I looked at it I was wondering
did anyone else notice this sort of
shrinking of the market well when I
looked into it I realized that people
didn't look at it as their team ordinary
people the way they looked at seafood
was like this it's not an unusual human
characteristic to reduce the natural
world down to very few elements we did
it before ten thousand years ago when we
came out of our caves if you look at
fire pits from ten thousand years ago
you'll see
raccoons you'll see you know wolves
you'll see all kinds of different
creatures but if you telescope to the
age of you know 2,000 years ago you'll
see these four mammals pigs cows sheep
and goats it's true of birds - you look
at the menus in New York City
restaurants 150 years ago 200 years ago
you'll see snipe Woodcock grouse dozens
of ducks dozens of geese but telescope
ahead to the age of modern animal
husbandry and you'll see for turkeys
ducks chicken and geese
so it makes sense that we've had in this
direction but but how have we headed in
this direction
well first it's a very very new problem
this is the way we've been fishing the
oceans over the last 50 years world war
two was a tremendous incentive to arm
ourselves in war against fish all of the
technology that we perfected during
World War two
sonar light weight polymers all these
things were redirected towards fish and
so you see this tremendous buildup in
fishing capacity while drooping in the
course of time from the end of World War
two to the present time and right now
that means we're taking between 80 and
90 million metric tons out of the sea
every year that's the equivalent of the
human weight of China taken out of the
sea every year and it's no coincidence
that I use China as the example because
China is now the largest fishing nation
in the world well that's only half the
story
the other half of the story is this
incredible boom in fish farming and
aquaculture which is now only in last
year too
starting to exceed the amount of wild
fish that we produce so that if you add
wild fish and farm fish together you get
the equivalent of two China's created
from the ocean each and every year and
again it's not a coincidence that I use
China as the example because China in
addition to being the biggest catcher of
fish is also the biggest farmer of fish
so let's look though at the four choices
that we are making right now the first
one the most by far the most consumed
seafood in America and in much of the
West is shrimp shrimp in the wild is a
wild product is a terrible product 5 10
15 pounds of wild fish are regularly
killed to bring 1 pound of shrimp to the
market they're also incredibly fuel
inefficient to bring to the market in a
recent study that was produced out of
Dalhousie University was found that
draggy for shrimp is one of the most
carbon intensive ways of fishing that
you can find so you can farm them and
people do farm them and they farm them a
lot in this very area problem is the
place where you farm shrimp is in these
wild habitats in mangrove forests now
look at those lovely roots coming down
those are the things that hold soil
together protect coasts create habitats
for all sort of young fish young shrimp
all sorts of things that are important
to the
environment well this is what happens to
a lot of coastal mangrove forests we've
lost millions of acres of coastal
mangroves over the last 30 or 40 years
that rate of destruction has slowed but
we're still in a major mangrove deficit
the other thing that's going on here is
a phenomenon that the filmmaker mark
Benjamin called grinding Nemo this
phenomenon is very very relevant to
anything that you've ever seen on a
tropical reef because what's going on
right now we have shrimp draggers
dragging for shrimp catching a huge
amount of bycatch that by catch in turn
gets ground up and turned into shrimp
food and sometimes many of these vessels
manned by slaves are catching the
so-called trash fish fish that we would
love to see on a reef grinding them up
and turning them into shrimp feed an
ecosystem literally eating itself and
spitting out shrimp the next most
consumed seafood in American also
throughout the West is tuna so tuna is
this ultimate global fish these huge
management areas have to be observed in
order for tuna to be well-managed our
own management area called a regional
fisheries management organization is
called ICAT the international vention
for the conservation of Atlantic tunas
the great naturalist Carl Safina once
called it the International conspiracy
to catch all the tunas of course we've
seen an incredible improvement in ICAT
in the last few years there is total
room for improvement but it remains to
be said that tuna is a global fish and
to manage it we have to manage the globe
well we could also try to grow tuna but
tuna is a spectacularly bad animal for
aquaculture many people don't know this
but tuna are warm-blooded they can heat
their bodies 20 degrees above ambient
temperature they can swim at over 40
miles an hour so pretty much eliminates
all the advantages of farming a fish
right if the farm fishes or fish is
cold-blooded it doesn't move too much
that's a great thing for growing protein
but if you've got this crazy wild
creature that swims at 40 miles an hour
and eats its blood not a great candidate
for aquaculture the next creature and
most consumed seafood in America and
throughout the West is salmon now salmon
got its plundering too but it didn't
really necessarily happen through
fishing this is my home state of
Connecticut
it used to be home to a lot of wild
salmon but if you look at this map of
Connecticut every dot on that map is a
dam there are over 3,000 dams in the
state of Connecticut I often said this
is why people in Connecticut are so so
uptight it if somebody could just
unblock Connecticut's Chi I feel that we
could have an infinitely better world
but I made this particular comment at a
convention once of national parks
officers and this guy from North
Carolina sidled up to me says you know
yatin be so hard on your connecticut
because we here in North Carolina
we got 35,000 a.m. so it's a national
epidemic it's an international epidemic
and there are dams everywhere and these
are precisely the things that stop wild
salmon from reaching their spawning
grounds so as a result we've turned to
aquaculture and salmon is one of the
most successful at least from a numbers
point of view when they first started
farming salmon it could take as many as
six pounds of wild fish to make a single
pound of salmon the industry has to its
credit greatly improved they've gotten
it below 2 to 1 although it's a little
bit of a cheat because if you look at
the way aquaculture feed is produced
their measuring pellets pounds of
pellets per pound of salmon those
pellets are in turn reduced fish so the
actual what's called the FIFO the fish
in and the fish out kind of hard to say
but in any case credit to the industry
it has lowered the amount of fish per
pound of salmon problem is we've also
gone crazy with the amount of salmon
that we're producing aquaculture is the
fastest growing food system on the
planet it's growing it's something like
7% per year and so even though we're
doing less per fish to bring it to the
market we're still killing a lot of
these little fish and it's not just fish
that we're feeding fish to we're all st.
feeding fish to chickens and pigs so we
got chickens and they're eating fish but
weirdly we also have fish that are
eating chickens because the byproducts
of chickens feathers blood bone get
ground up and fed to fish so I've been
wonder is there a fish that ate a
chicken that ate a fish
it's sort of a reworking of the chicken
and egg thing anyway altogether though
it results in a terrible mess what
you're talking about is something
between 20 and 30 million metric tons of
wild creatures that are taken from the
ocean and used and ground-up that's the
equivalent of a third of a China or of
entire United States of humans I've
taken out of the sea each and every year
the last of the four is a kind of
amorphous thing it's you know what the
industry calls white fish
there's many fish that gets cycled into
this white fish thing but the way to
kind of tell the story I think is
through that classic piece of American
culinary innovation the fillet a fish
sandwich so the fillet fish sandwich
actually started as halibut and it
started because a local franchise owner
found that when he served his McDonald's
on on Friday nobody came because it was
a Catholic community they needed fish so
Ray Kroc he went to Ray Kroc he said I'm
gonna bring you a fish sandwich can be
made out of halibut Ray Kroc said I
don't think it's gonna work I want to do
a hula burger and there's gonna be a
it's a slice of pineapple on a button
but let's do this let's have a bet who's
ever sandwich you know sells more that
will be the winning sandwich well it's
kind of sad for the ocean that the hula
burger didn't win so he made his halibut
sandwich
unfortunately though the sandwich came
in at 30 cents ray wanted the sandwich
come in at 25 cents so he turned to
Atlantic cod we all know what happened
to Atlantic cod in New England so now
the filet-o-fish sandwich is made out of
Alaska pollock it's the largest fin fish
fishery in the United States two to
three billion pounds of fish taken out
of the sea every single year if we go
through the Pollock the next choice is
probably going to be tilapia tilapia is
one of those fish nobody ever heard of
20 years ago it's actually a very
efficient converter of plant protein
into animal protein and it's been a
godsend to the third world it's actually
a tremendously sustainable solution goes
from an egg to an adult in nine months
problem is that when you look about the
West it doesn't do what the West wants
it to do it really doesn't have what's
called an oily fish profile it doesn't
have the EPA and DHA omega-3s that we
all think are going to make us live
forever
so what do we do I mean first of all
what about this poor fish
the clue pants the fish that represent a
huge part of that 20 to 30 million
metric tons well one possibility that a
lot of conservationists have raised is
could we eat them could we eat them
directly instead of feeding them to
salmon there are arguments for it they
are tremendously fuel efficient to bring
to market a fraction of the fuel costs
of save shrimp and at the very top of
the carbon efficiency scale they also
are omega-3 rich of great source for EPA
and DHA so that is a potential and if we
were to go down that route what I would
say is instead of paying a few bucks a
pound or a few bucks a ton really and
making it into aqua feed could we have
the catch and double the price for the
fishermen and make that our way of
treating these particular fish other
possibility though which is much more
interesting is looking at bivalves
particularly mussels now mussels are
very high in EPA DHA there they're
similar to canned tuna they are also
extremely fuel-efficient to bring a
pound of mussels to market is about a
thirtieth of the carbon as required to
bring beef to market they require no
forage fish they actually get their
omega-3s by filtering the water of
microalgae in fact that's where omega-3s
come from they don't come from fish
microalgae
make the omega-3s they're only bio
concentrated in fish mussels and other
bivalves do tremendous amounts of water
filtration a single muscle can filter
dozens of gallons every single day and
this is incredibly important when we
look at the world right now
nitrification over use of phosphates in
our waterways are causing tremendous
algal blooms over 400 new dead zones
have been created in the last 20 years
tremendous sources of marine life death
we also could look at not a fish at all
we could look at a vegetable we could
look at seaweed that helps all these
different varieties of things that can
be high in omega-3s can be high in
proteins tremendously good things they
filter the water just like mussels do
and weirdly enough it turns out that you
can actually feed this to cows now I'm
not a big fan of cattle but if you
wanted to keep growing cattle in a time
and place where water resources are
limited you're growing seaweed in the
water you don't have to water it major
consideration and the last fish is a
quest
mark we have the ability to create
aquacultured fish that creates a net
gain of marine protein for us this
creature would have to be vegetarian it
would have to be fast-growing it'd have
to be adaptable to a changing climate
and we'd have to have that oily fish
profile that EPA DHA omega-3 fatty acid
profile that we're looking for this
exists kind of on paper I have been
reporting on these subjects for 15 years
every time I do a new story somebody
tells me we can do all that we can do it
we've figured it all out we can produce
a fish that's a net gain of marine
protein and has omega-3 is great it
doesn't seem to be getting scaled up it
is time to scale this up if we do 30
million metric tons of seafood a third
of the world catch stays in the water so
I guess what I'm saying is this is what
we've been going with we tend to go with
our appetites rather than our minds but
if we went with this or some
configuration of it we might have a
little more of this thank you